[Music]
foreign
everybody are we ready for the scene
equation of the day
all right what do you get when you add
one minute and 24 seconds of previously
ons to 24 seconds of logos that's right
kids sins
I get that these guys are [__] but
you tell me that this literal child
abuse didn't give you all of the
uncomfortable winces and I will call you
a liar or the police it's right on the
Galaxy's edge of being too fan servicey
but these two are hilarious together and
I can't help but remove Us in for this
ironically On Target gag any update yet
considering the kill to death ratio of
your typical storm trooper I'm not sure
why these guys are in such a hurry to
end their rather cushy collect moff
Gideon's lunch and enjoy the view
assignment he just killed an officer for
interrupting him I understand killing a
trooper or two to make a point and flex
your power but at some point it just
seems wasteful if the Empire is gone
aren't Stormtroopers in limited Supply
maybe just render a few of them
unconscious to make your point resource
management is important the last thing
that you want is to give giddy in a bag
and have him open it up and find
whatever it is okay okay look yeah but
you're now robbing us of the opportunity
for these guys to get into a weekend at
giddy's situation with a dead grogu
Star Wars continues to prove just how
useless stormtrooper armor is he's
wearing thick gloves and yet grogu's
tiny teeth Were Somehow powerful enough
to hurt his fingers
stop punching your boss's new child
slash pet slash lunch
you remind him to me immediate immediate
are you refusing my request no I'm
telling you to get out of here sounds an
awful lot like your refusing ig11's
request to me
the Star Wars Universe have a concept of
Hell sure Anakin apparently knows what
an angel looks like but that's not
explained either listen vocabulary
matters just because this is a common
phrase on our planet doesn't mean it
would be here too so just give her
something different to say or make them
swear in Mandarin like Firefly did
they're setting up the eweb oh no not an
e-web how the hell will they ever escape
the eweb
is an e-web it's over Reef cargo goes
all Hudson from Aliens on us and if this
weapon is that powerful I suppose he has
a point I mean there's no way moff
Gideon would do something outrageous
like give them an entire day before I
will give you until Nightfall muffer
[__]
why would you have a vent to a sewer
directly behind a bench where people
would sit and drink have a hard time
believing anyone would sit in a bar that
smells like a sewer what do you think
you are New York City I'm out of charges
says the script members of my escort
have completed assembly of an e-web
heavy repeating Blaster okay I couldn't
help but research what this is and it
turns out it's a pretty badass piece of
gear that was used in The Empire Strikes
Back cool nice call back however its
full title is in placement weapon heavy
Blaster which means moth is pulling a
PIN number by calling it an implacement
weapon heavy Blaster heavy repeating
Blaster stop shortening things and then
saying the words you've already
shortened or perhaps the decommissioned
Mandalorian Hunter din Jaren villain
full names the heroes he's trapped and
goes through their history as a way of
asserting dominance cliche or as we say
in the biz Hans grubering I will give
you until Nightfall
and then I will have
you sleep why do villains always do this
all he's doing is
he really wants to force their hand he
should give them two minutes to
surrender not several hours I understand
the writers need to give our heroes a
way to escape into season two but there
are smarter ways to do that don't upload
me to a mind player as long as you put
enough points into your intelligence
stat you should be fine Cara you only
need a dc-15 intelligence saving throw
to avoid its mind blast attack and even
if you fail and get stunned you get to
re-roll that saving throw at the end of
each turn trust me 5D mind players
aren't nearly as bad as they used to be
in 3.5 e uh or that's what some nerd
told me yeah [__] nerds am I right
it's moth Gideon no
MAF Gideon was executed for war crimes
how do these pretty regular looking
Stormtroopers talk about moff Gideon as
if he's the poster Sith for what's left
of the Empire but Mando revealing his
identity comes as a huge shock to Cara
and karga Mandalorian is in a race it's
a Creed Roll commercial huh sorry about
that everyone that really felt like a
roll commercials moment I guess I'll
just send it for breaking the fourth
wall because if there wasn't a helmet in
the way Pedro Pascal would be staring
directly into the camera for that line
This flashbacks position of civilians
being killed goes on for all of the
sometime we get it the Empire sucks
sheesh oh if twister taught me anything
it's the one a kid is put in a basement
the father's going to die starting to
get the feeling dense parents aren't
walking away from this one and for
clarity I meant the movie Twister not
the game although come to think of it
the game would work too
foreign
Justice also looks like we've got a kid
whose name Rhymes within hides
underground while Imperial baddies kill
their parents until they're rescued by
Future Mentor cliche okay maybe that's
not a cliche but the similarities to
Rogue one seem unnecessary in a Galaxy
full of potential origin stories cool
shot but there are still plenty of
droids around could they really afford
to dramatically unfold their hand and
wait for din to climb out moth Gideon
was an ISP officer during The Purge
that's how I know it's him what kind of
proof is that how can he know moth was
the only ISB officer connected to
Mandalore why is it only an ISB officer
that could know his name look I'm sure
there's something I'm missing here but I
wish someone would tell me exactly what
because cargo and Kara take this is
unquestioning proof that moff Gideon is
well moth Gideon he says he needs us
which means the child Got Away safely I
was worried when the up not didn't
respond stop calling this person you've
come to implicitly trust and respect by
their species you don't call Cara the
human or Luke the ungodly CGI rendering
of my nightmares okay I know that's not
until season two but appears sitting as
much as possible fulfilling my base
function which is to nurse and protect
not that the shots of grogu laughing
while ig11 blows [__] up aren't awesome
but if your directive is to nurse and
protect wouldn't you take the child
further away from danger running the kid
into an active conflict Zone would seem
to violate that directive pretty
fundamentally especially when the razor
Crest was an option punching a guy in
metal laser-proof armor only members of
the bad batch could get away with that
nonsense Mando rips the eweb off of its
Mount presumably so that he can make it
a mobile vessel of pewing Fury but since
he ends up standing in the same spot and
spinning around why didn't he just leave
it on the mount with its stability
intact and save himself a copyright
lawsuit from the master chief I know
Stormtroopers aren't exactly the masters
of tactical Warfare but this [__]
literally runs toward the line of fire
created by the super powerful death
Cannon why are they still trying to get
into the bar both Mando and grogu are
clearly outside on the street and you
might say but TV sins taking the bar
offers a tactical advantage and we'd say
stuff at you scruffy Nerf herders
Stormtroopers aren't that smart like And
subscribe yeah Stormtroopers couldn't
hit the broadside of a bantha but
shouldn't the priority here be taking
out the extremely exposed car on Mando
we barely see a shot even come near them
I mean what the hell is Moth Gideon
doing right now washing his tights
wait what didn't they just blow the door
off with a [__] grenade how is it all
fixed and properly shutting now what
kind of a bar has a reloading door I'm
not gonna make it go trying to convince
the audience that the show's titular
character will die when season 2 has
already been ordered and sinned I'm
gonna need to take this thing off
coats of Honor are cool and all but the
mandalorians are basically an endangered
species right now they're taking the
helmet off can let her save his life
then do it yeah yeah I hear you this is
the way and I have spoken but that's not
gonna matter all that much in about five
minutes when a Droid finds a loophole is
small and ridiculous as a midichlorian
when you get to the Mandalorian chord
you show them that do you want to tell
your friends where the top secret covert
is before you kick the bucket they'll
probably need directions guys we want to
make sure the Stormtrooper looks
different because they have a
flamethrower and any suggestions
um how about some unsettling red paint
that makes it look like the skin of his
helmet is being pulled back to reveal a
fleshy under maw that's gross and it
doesn't say flame Trooper to me I love
it let me have a Warrior's death we just
saw grogu use four ceiling powers in the
last episode to save grief cargus so why
can't they do the same thing for din
here is someone saving their Force
powers for more dramatic scene are they
I bet they are I bet they are
she will at this point we've had so many
days that it's hard to buy into the
stakes of these near-death situations
it's especially baffling when you
realize that a matter of hours ago grogo
chose not to use their powers to save
quill a character we like more than at
least 50 percent of the people in this
room the living thing is seen me without
my helmet since I
soya Creed
I am not a living thing I'm truly
conflicted about the helmet removal I'm
all for seeing Pedro Pascal but doesn't
this feel a little unearned yes it's
debatable as to whether ig-11 is truly
alive but that doesn't feel like an
argument that's going to hold up in
Mando court and spoilers for season two
it doesn't it's almost like the show
just felt bad for not showing us Pedro
like we know this could have been
anybody in the suit with Pedro in a
recording booth but we want to show you
that he put the armor on at least once
never mind that undermines one of the
characters core [__] beliefs this is
a back to spray
it will heal you in a matter of hours
back to spray back to spray that comes
in a spray form every time we've seen it
used back this kept in a tank and the
character has to be submerged to benefit
from its miraculous healing properties
someone should tell Boba Fett so he
doesn't waste half of his series just
napping in a fishbowl dreaming of
electric Exposition also you're only
mentioning this now this [__] listen
to Cara and man to argue instead of
saying I've managed to bottle the
essence of plot convenience and can fix
whatever we need to fix so there's
really no need to get all emotional and
also episode 2 attack of the also if the
back to spray is that powerful why did
you need to remove the [__] helmet
just spray that [__] under there and
leave the man with his honor stand I'll
try to find tracks
we're close and looking at the ground
was somehow a physical impossibility
while leaning on Cara and looking at the
ground
's pass tell of battles between
Mandalore the Great
and an order of sorcerers called Jedi
that fought with such Powers there are
around 30 years between Order 66 and the
events of the Mandalorian if that's not
enough time for my best friend to forget
about the time he tricked me into
wearing my retainer post urinal bath
it's not enough time for the Galaxy to
forget about the light sword police
Sorcerers who patrolled the Galaxy
you're expected to search the Galaxy for
the home of this creature and deliver it
to a race of enemy Sorcerers Mando would
obey the Creed of TV sins a Creed until
it is of age or reunited with its own
kind
you are as its father so just because
you say the word creed a million times
you just expect Bando to make that kind
of sacrifice With Arms Wide Open you are
a clan of two what's up Mando cool badge
I have no idea you joined the mass the
the what the mudhorn appreciation
society yeah I've got a cousin that
rules with those guys nice group of bit
intense no no no this is my my signature
ah damn it IG please call the outer
hallway kudos for saying please but does
zaiji just take orders from anybody
until you know it it will not listen to
your commands what is it a Pokemon
you're telling me this jetpack can
disobey its user funny how none of the
other mandalorians in the siege of
Mandalore episodes of Clone Wars seem to
have rebellious jet packs or at least
that's what some nerd told me hey Chad
toss me a cold one while I fixed this
car and I can't do it I'm the nerd I'm
the nerd restock your Munitions did
Mando level up or something me gets a
new outfit detail and new weapon and a
complete refill of ammo is the show
gonna auto save because the big boss
fights coming up I just carry this for
dinner oh so now we're just calling him
dinjarin whenever and in front of
whoever the [__] we want how will Mandu
ever be able to identify future mobs who
happen to be hunting him down hmm I'd
say it's pretty embarrassing to lose to
a person fighting with a hammer when you
outnumber them and have guns but all
y'all lost teddy bears on the moon of
Endor the Stormtrooper bar continues to
plummet and we will not stop sitting
that they are still the Empire's weapon
of choice this is the Lava River
unnecessary observations
at some point during the Star Wars
holiday special I seen the fact that
nobody ever thought to engineer poor
R2D2 legs in arms upon reflection I
would like to take that sin back and
transfer to this [__] nightmare fuel
I don't suppose anybody here speaks
Droid nope not a single person hey IG
can you think of anyone in the boat that
speaks Droid no me neither quite the
puzzle I will eliminate the enemy and
you will escape you don't have that kind
of Firepower pal
you wouldn't even get to Daylight he
says to the Droid that single-handedly
took out a small town of Stormtroopers
while carrying a child in a damn Baby
Bjorn sadly there's no scenario where
the child is saved in which I survive no
scenario no scenario that is a mighty
amount of confidence that doesn't
account for sudden grow gooing Jedi
cameos or well the more obvious factor
that Stormtroopers can't shoot tin cans
10 feet in front of them
look we all love T2 but stealing is
stealing and stealing is like one of
those actual sins he won't next time he
still wants grogu alive and you're
holding the child so yeah he'll continue
missing come on baby do the magic hand
thing
kids
this is forcing badass let's go but also
this works Shields are a thing in the
Star Wars Universe right like we've
definitely seen them before so why don't
thai fighters have them and don't give
me some [__] about it being too
expensive or cumbersome if the Rebellion
can afford them and fit them on x-wings
the Empire should have zero issues doing
the same
thank you
moth Gideon survives this well would you
look at that the jet pack is still
obeying commands I'm starting to think
that the nice lady with the murder
hammers was full of [__] oh yeah more
[__] porn I love the razor Crest I hope
it sticks around for a long time to come
he has a [__] ing light slash dark slash
saber slash sword thing why the [__] is
he only busting this out now in fact why
is the show only busting this out now
it's as if they've been saving it for
some big end of season sting oh
thank you
no one cared who I was till I put on the
mask what do we learn Palmer I don't
know sir
I don't [__] know either I guess we
learned not to do it again yes sir to
find out what we did yes sir it's uh
hard to say
[Applause]
Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne
identify yourself drop it Dead or Alive
you are coming with me
[Applause]
God
due to the nakatomic corporation's
Legacy of greed around the globe they
are about to be told a lesson in the
real use of power
you will be Witnesses
[Applause]
hey it's Enrico Palazzo if I pull that
off will you die it would be extremely
painful you're a big guy for you
[Applause]
well I don't believe it it's Henry
Baskin my next door neighbor he's had
enough of being a space ghost I am not a
living thing bureaucrat Conrad you are
technically correct the best kind of
correct
[Music]
that was falling with style